the clark county school district and
unions will also have to try to
collaborate on what the rules would be
for exemptions i checked in with some
local physicians about medical
exemptions today and they tell me it's
extremely rare to have a condition which
would prevent someone from getting the
covet 19 vaccine dr stacy mchale is an
ob gyn and the president of the clark
county medical society she says someone
seeking a medical exemption would need
to get it from their physician who's
aware of their medical history and
understands their need for an exemption
one reason for an exemption might
include an allergic reaction perhaps if
the patient is allergic to a component
in the vaccine another reason may be an
underlying inflammatory heart condition
but again she says this is all very rare
as we've reported more employers are
mandating vaccines and here's what dr
mchale says she's experienced so far
there have been patients that have
already
okay dr mchale basically explained how
some patients have asked her for
vaccines and she's said no because she
felt like they did not need it they did
not have a reason for a medical
exemption now she also says for patients
who are pregnant or thinking about
becoming pregnant those who are
immunocompromised
are have undergoing cancer treatments on
dialysis have chronic diseases it's
recommended they get the covid 19
vaccine now as for religious exemptions
they also appear to be rare some
religious groups are saying they will
not issue exemptions one example is the
roman catholic diocese of las vegas back
to you